howdy Duty gamer friends you're probably
here because you have a Game Pass
subscription and need to know what to
play next and guess what pal you came to
the right place because we're gonna go
over some of the best games to play
right now on the service
just the other day during Xbox's
developer direct they announced and
surprisingly dropped this hyper colorful
Saturday morning ROM of an action rhythm
game and that isn't the only surprise it
comes from developer Tango softworks the
studio Behind The Evil Within franchise
and the recent spooky action game
ghostwire Tokyo talk about having Range
High Five Rush is a vibrant step away
from the horror stuff that Tango soft
works is usually known for instead
leaning into a bright world with bright
humor set to a Rock soundtrack that'll
have you beating up baddies to the
rocking beat you play as chai a wannabe
rock star turn corporate experiment who
uses his passion for music to slam his
way out while taking down corporate
bigwigs in the process and the
soundtrack also rules featuring Black
Keys and Nine Inch Nails just to name a
few all of that is stitched together
with a thick line art style that
captures the look of an animated cartoon
so damn well it also has a cat and you
can pet that cat pretty rock star move
shy
what could I possibly say about this
game it is Goldeneye it's the Monumental
Nintendo 64 classic from 1997 and now
it's on a Microsoft console that's right
it is the definitive first person
shooter before Halo before Call of Duty
this is a game that forged as many
friendships as it destroyed what a
nostalgic look back on the many many
many young Gamers that sat in a room
together eight junk food drink sugary
drinks and karate chop the out of
each other why did it take 26 years to
bring this to consoles today is one of
the world's greatest Mysteries but that
doesn't matter because it is here and
whether you like it or not there is no
online multiplayer for this one it is
exclusively only local multiplayer
that's right no more comfortably sitting
on your couch with a headset and
insulting strangers online you have to
invite someone to your place and then
insult them to their face while playing
the game the old-fashioned way this
Faithfully recreated version features
support for dual analog sticks and a 16
by nine aspect ratio that goes up to 4K
these Blobby textures have never looked
better in glorious Blobby 4K and also of
course features the entire campaign
including the cheat mode all hail big
head mode
one of the most beloved and acclaimed
jrpg series is has finally arrived on
Xbox never saw that coming that's right
persona it's the series where you play
as a teenager tackling mature problems
with your ragtag group of friends going
through surreal dungeons fighting off
Shadow creatures and confronting the
darker sides of people from within if
you're new to Persona and don't know
where to begin lucky for you you can
basically start wherever you want each
one features its own unique story and
mystery with a new cast of characters
Persona 3 is about the Dark Hour a
period of time in which the city is
consumed by a shadowy force where other
worldly monsters emerge Persona 4
surrounds a murder mystery in a small
town where the victims are broadcast on
television the night before the murder
occurs and Persona 5 focuses around the
trials of defeating the distorted and
perverse desires that fester in the
people around the main character and
despite these often dire and intense
obstacles between dungeons you'll have
the chance to do mundane life-like
things like going to school and learning
and forging relationships and going to
the movies or whatever some of you may
get that in real life already but how
many of you can say you enter a
television at midnight and beat up weird
shadowy Blobby things huh
you know what maybe you don't want to
rehash the exhausting years of your high
school life maybe you want to hunt down
giant monsters because yeah the ones
Nintendo switch exclusive Monster Hunter
rise is now on Game Pass this
installment in the long-running series
is a versatile take on the gameplay loop
from The Originals putting in an
emphasis on mobility and scaling the
open World by equipping players with a
Nifty wire bug a tool that allows you to
zip up walls or to perform cool attacks
it also allows the ability to saddle on
monsters and control them to wreak havoc
in traditional Monster Hunter fashion
the game is deep with 14 weapon types to
choose from each with their own very
distinct approach and will pit you
against massive monsters that you can
either hunt down completely alone or
with pales the monster hunter games can
be a steep learning curve for those new
to the series and while rise is no
exception to depth it can serve as a
fresh starting point for new players as
there's many new additions that have
changed up the tried and true formula in
cool and meaningful ways
Eastward is a game about a society on
the brink of collapse a concept that is
depicted beautifully by the makeshift
City the game takes place in a city that
is barely standing up on its own on the
foundation of crumbling buildings the
human population is fleeting and a
deadly toxin ravages across the land and
while it sounds absolutely Dreadful
Eastward is really quite a Charming
Adventure game filled with levity as you
try to escape a society standing on its
last leg the game will have you
traveling around meeting its inhabitants
fending off monsters in the wilderness
solving puzzles and trudging through
dungeons the tower Adventurer is
juxtaposed with a bright and upbeat
soundtrack and scenarios that add some
much needed humor in the midst of all
its misery plus you can beat up stuff
with a frying pan and have mystical
Powers so that's cool
now here's a game you didn't know you
needed in your life potion craft that's
right this little charmer has you
physically interacting with your tools
and ingredients to become a master
potion maker fulfill your deepest
desires to run your own potion shop win
the hearts of customers with your
remarkable concoctions and in the
process become a potion making Pro that
means picking your own ingredients
collecting all the right stuff mashing
it up mixing in a cauldron heating up
the coals stirring the whole shebang and
of course you're running a shop so
you'll need to meet the needs of your
clientele and who knows what they'll be
asking for a healing potion poison a
poisonous healing potion it's your craft
after all potion craft so bottom up how
you see them fit make new potions get
weird get wacky get magical I don't care
be The Alchemist of your wildest dreams
so that's that hopefully you found
something here to fill that void of time
in your life now if there's one game on
this list that won't only take a ton of
time to finish but might even stimulate
some sort of desire to talk and Forge
bonds with people there's always Persona
and there's three of them to choose from
or you can just stick to being a recluse
Alchemist and making poison whatever
whatever people want from you your
choice as always I implore you to try
and play something you normally wouldn't
what's the harm in just trying something
out anyways have fun with all the gaming
enjoy be well till next time see you
later
[Music]